el congreso de mexico le dijo no a la
reforma constitucional de energía
eléctrica el partido de gobierno no
logró convencer a un número
significativo de legisladores de
oposición para aprobar la ley que
limitaría la participación de empresas
privadas y extranjeras en el sector de
la energía eléctrica
aunque fueron 275 votos a favor frente a
los 233 en contra no fue suficiente para
los 334 votos necesarios dos tercios de
la cámara baja del congreso para
realizar el cambio en la carta magna
pues una visión del país donde se crea y
se sabe la necesidad de un sistema
eléctrico mexicano fortalecido donde la
participación de los privados sea una
competencia justa legal y no alevosa por
parte de las empresas extranjeras
mientras que algunos legisladores
oficialistas gritaron traidores a la
oposición no pasará con la respuesta en
coro de aquellos que se oponen a la
reforma
en medio de un debate que comenzó con la
presencia de casi todos los 500
diputados en una sesión plenaria
especial en concreto la reforma busca
limitar las plantas de energías
renovables construidas por compañías
extranjeras e impedir que la
participación del sector privado en la
producción de energía supere el 46 por
ciento dándole así más poder a la
comisión federal de electricidad tras la
derrota en la cámara de diputados-
andrés manuel lópez obrador calificó el
voto como una traición y anunció su
llamado plan b para qué
nació analicemos el litio y que solo
se utilice para beneficio
del desarrollo nacional
el mandatario hizo un llamado a los
legisladores para que aprobaran la
medida cuanto antes ya que ahora sólo se
necesita una mayoría simple para aprobar
la ley que permitiría que el mineral
utilizado en la fabricación de baterías
eléctricas fuera explotado
exclusivamente por el estado